hard work versus talent so I got a
question from YouTube I love you guys
saying Saucer Roden to say can you do a
video on hard work versus talent just
like Will Smith did and I want to know
your thoughts so Will Smith did a great
job I'm no Will Smith but I love his
view on hard work versus talent I've
never really viewed myself as
particularly talented view myself as you
know slightly above average and talent
and where I excel is ridiculous
sickening work ethic you know while the
other guys sleeping I'm working what
other guys eaten I'm working only thing
that I see that is distinctly different
about me is I'm not afraid to die on a
treadmill I will run it would not be
outworked I will not be outworked
right period yeah you know you might
have more talent than me you might be
smarter than me you might be sexier than
me you might be all of those things you
got it on me in nine categories but if
we get on the treadmill together right
there's two things you're getting off
first
yeah or I'm gonna die it's really that
simple so I'm a little Smith but here is
my view on it since you asked for it I
believe that you have to be great at
what you do to have success in any in
any field right if you want to have
success you have to be great at your
craft you have to have the skills and
you have to work on it the thing is any
skill can be acquired you can learn any
skill that's what a skill is it's
something that you can learn and a lot
of arch burns will look at a feel that
they want to get into and then look at
whoever the best is and they say wow
that guy's got so many see I can't do
that I could never be like that person
and because they don't have the skills
they don't even try they're not
interested they just quit right there on
the spot you can develop
any skill it doesn't matter that's what
a skill is here's a quick example and
I'd like to share so I'm with a talent
agency so I have an agent he's out
representing me closing deals book deals
all sorts of fun stuff and I almost
didn't get into the agency so he called
me he found some of the stuff I was
doing and said he really liked what I
stood for but I wasn't good enough on
camera I was below like the base
standard quality guidelines that they
look for so like their average might be
here he was like the lowest of what they
would accept it and I was like down here
so you're not good enough is that you
have a powerful message that's why we
like you but but you need to get better
in front of the camera we're going to do
anything with you so we're going to take
a gamble on you and we'll go and we'll
try it out and I realized that for me to
reach my goal of helping a billion
entrepreneurs I had to get better I had
to get better on camera I had to get
better with my videos I had to get
better with my my presentations my
seminars my workshops my quino's
everything had to be better and I
started applying myself to learn the
craft and it came from researching
people who I look up to guys like Les
Brown and Gary Vaynerchuk and et er
Thomas looking at what they're doing and
it came from just practicing like a
ridiculous amount of practice and I've
done a thousand videos now and most of
my put up on my channel a thousand
videos thinking about that the first
videos that I did it took me a whole day
to do one video a whole day I stressed
out I had to make it perfect you know I
was I was crappy at it and slowly I got
better I could do them faster and now
there's a thousand videos that I've made
two videos are going up on my channel
every day and the funny thing is in the
past three months about three months
maybe four months ago when I signed up
with the agency I am now being used
within the agency as the best practice
to follow they tell new people coming on
in their existing clients you should be
doing more of what Evans doing look at
some of these videos and model them are
you kidding me I was the worst guy I'm
is the worst god I was a guy who was way
below their base standard of quality 3-4
months ago that was me I was the worst
guy in the company and now I'm being
looked up to as as one of the best to
look at and the difference is the work
because these guys have years of
experience that I didn't have I had
nothing their use of experience doing it
and I quickly outpaced them because I
just worked harder than they did and I
picked up the skills because I was
passionate about learning it when you're
passionate about something you learn it
so much faster than when you're forced
to do it and I picked up the skills so
now if you compare look at the reasons
why I'm doing two videos every single
day that are launching most of the
people at the agency they struggle to
get one video out per week one video per
week are you kidding me do you want this
is this is this a goal of yours what are
you doing how do you only do one video a
week and that's how you pass by the
people who have way more skills and you
because you can learn any skill but
these guys aren't working hard enough I
respond to every single YouTube comment
pretty much every tweet that comes back
to me I'm almost always responded to
every single one that comes in now maybe
that's not yeah I'm like I'm gonna be
able to continue that as I get more
popular but I get a lot of comments
you're like 40 50 comments a day that I
have to respond to and I respond to
everybody and I have way more comments
than other people at the agency and I'm
still responding to everybody and I'm
still making new videos based on the
questions that come in from you guys why
am I making this video this is a
question it's the work that's why I'm
out pacing these guys everything like oh
what am i doing I don't know what I'm
doing how do I grow this thing you're
just not working hard enough you don't
want it badly enough and I think the
main reasons a lot of these people will
get into it at the agency have this you
know they want to be on camera they want
to be on TV but they don't have a real
reason for it I don't care about camera
I don't care about TV I don't care about
presentations I want to help
entrepreneurs being on TV and camera and
present that just helps me get there now
that's what I need to do to get there
I'm going to get there and I'm going to
be passionate about I'm going to learn
why need to learn to get to the next
step but I have something driving me
forward that I'm passionate about that's
what you need to find when you find that
when you tap into that you could pick up
any skill and it'll happen like that
because you're going to apply yourself
to your craft you're going to look down
it's 9:00 in the morning going to get
started it's gonna be six o'clock at
night you said where did the time go
and it's not going to be from playing
computer games for hours and hours and
hours right you might I don't know when
I was younger I could do that sit down
at 9:00 in the morning play a computer
game and it's 2:00 in the afternoon is
that where did all the time go and you
still want to play more computer games
that's the cut that's what you need to
get into that's the kind of passion you
need to find for something great that
you want to create and when you can do
that then the skills are nothing you'll
pick them up so quickly so tap into your
passion and believe those are watching
like the video give a thumbs up below
thank you for the great question you
have a question for me leave it in the
comments I also love the hero you have
to think if you want leave a comment
underneath and subscribe to the channel
if you want more videos like this thank
you so much I'll see you soon